yo welcome to this video let's change
gears for one moment and go efore
against st Vela no particular reason why
against him but I just want to have a
different position just once yep and he
plays the Sicilian let's see if the
Russell Nemo at least the line that I
feel and I'm not like an expert but i
feel that i'm reasonably ok with normal
museum and don't need to know much
concrete theory now Queen d2 Bishop h6
would be nice to get an yep so we
prevents that but wow this is this is
weakening so let's let's attack this
this poor information let me night over
to g3
okay so what am I going to do here maybe
f4 here like directly f4 f5 yep let's
try that not totally sure but
Jim probably has to take it him if he's
not taking on puzzle I know okay if ya
I'm having quick rook g1 but but still I
guess he had to take that
so a fun way I have Bishop f4 also it's
not a bad move Bishop f4 Queen moves
rope cheap one yes night h5 as a defense
but it's so let's load it Sam it's a
tempo and a pretty good pretty good
tempo on the Queen
hmm yeah rook g one night h 5 ER somehow
holding doesn't look great but it seems
to be okay yeah I still I have to play
that or what else night age five whom
what a weird kind of way to play no it
just gives me this pawn okay can she can
take h 6 ER I cannot win it right away
but after castles he still has to answer
this question okay just gives me the
pawn don't see you and draw back okay
then I'm taking it
hmm okay so maybe just to g5 them that
should be bad for f4 f5 later so okay
let's let's put the king they're making
a little bit more making this a little
bit more secure and okay if you insist
to trade the bishop I don't mind it that
much I already have to have this some
taken taking the spawn so let's get the
night up
along didn't think about that move night
night then I can just take have to take
probably this is still a good position
there only four for the night
comes with a tempo um yeah I'm so
probably here g49 is a bit insecure but
I don't really see how we can use this
fact really don't see how okay so night
age six maybe 49 to 50 i see no it's not
really able to use that I don't see
don't see a place neither five looks
nice
yeah night would be great on air 597 of
course if he allows me to just [ __ ] him
I will gladly do so but what I don't
like is I have a weak background so
neither 7 yeah so just you're saying
it's no big deal I don't get it ok
quindi for yes but it's still not
helping at all yeah queen is also good
to have black resigns gracias yep
gracias is good yeah tricky tricky
position yeah this this early age 65 is
really a strong met Sonia not sure ok I
started with this immediate action not
sure about this but it looked
interesting so I really think you should
go on I'd age five I know a night on the
rim is doom and so on but the night on
age 5 is relatively safely placed down
and it it's not so clear what I'm doing
I was thinking I just probably go here
castles long and I wasn't sure about
this position at all maybe a form but he
has he has ideas like f5 may i have e 50
km yeah I don't know interesting but
this is yeah I mean he just gave me the
pawn I think computer wants to do this
and this and says it's okay why is it
okay for black
Wow okay yeah I cannot hold the pawn
interesting check and then that makes my
night look quite bad hmm remarkable okay
I'm not worse or anything but it's not
it's not an advantage ok this is this
however in comparison then must be quite
quite worse yeah I think I think I kept
kept a pretty good advantage no and this
is this is good yeah yeah so I didn't
didn't blunder anything and here the
night coming to f5 it's basically
winning the game the night is so strong
there ok you went into night f7 but it's
it's not not a big big difference if he
does something like that I don't see how
blackheads this I have the age porn I
have an extra porn better King
everything adds up so I'm probably
winning this this is this kind of
position as well ok well thanks for
watching